we should learn more a lot more about
the Special Counsel investigation into
Russian interference in the 2016
election in the next 24 hours we'll also
be hearing about the Republican probe of
alleged bias at the Department of
Justice here's chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge on the
prospects for a very big day tomorrow on
Friday the Special Counsel probe in
house Republican FBI investigation come
to a head
Robert Muller's team will submit memos
documenting their allegations the former
Trump campaign chairman Paul Manafort
violated his plea agreement mana force
legal team argues the Special Counsel
used strong-arm tactics to obtain
information their client does not have
or evidence that does not exist it's a
terrible situation for man afford
himself it's not a great form of the
prosecutors either because they really
can't use him as a witness in any case
against anybody earlier this week the
special counsel filed the sentencing
memo for former national security
adviser Mike Flynn with heavy redactions
a similar effort to shield sensitive
information is expected in the men
afford filing and a separate sentencing
memo for Michael Cohen the president's
former personal attorney
court records show Cohen who cut a deal
last week over lying to Congress about a
2016 Trump Moscow real estate project
has participated in seven voluntary
interview meetings with the special
counsels office legal observers predict
the next few weeks will be telling if
there aren't any new indictments that
would tell you that he's really
preparing a report to deliver to the
Congress about what his investigation is
uncovered relative to the president in
the campaign after withdrawing legal
efforts to quash a congressional
subpoena former FBI director James Comey
is on Capitol Hill Friday for a rare
closed-door interview under oath with
the House Judiciary Committee after
controversial text messages from FBI
agent Peter struck an FBI lawyer Lisa
Paige Republicans predict hard questions
on political bias in the Clinton email
and Russia investigations there's a
whole host of things that mr. Comey
knows and he's made statements on
some of them haven't been consistent
with a special counsel prosecuting Trump
associates for lying Republicans want
Comey to explain why he apparently did
not pursue similar allegations against
Hillary Clinton over her congressional
testimony about her email use Comey
transcript could be released as early as
Saturday the former FBI director said
the move is the closest he can get to a
public hearing Brett Catherine there's
also new information tonight about the
evidence in the Clinton Foundation
investigation
next week congressman mark meadows
chairman of the house freedom caucus is
holding a subcommittee hearing on the
investigation into the Clinton
Foundation as you recall a year ago the
US attorney in Utah John Huber was
tasked by then Attorney General Jeff
Sessions with the Clinton Foundation
among other issues tonight Meadows
confirms to Fox News three
whistleblowers have come forward with
hundreds of pages of evidence of
potential wrongdoing to include the
misappropriation of funds and quid pro
quo the Clinton Foundation has
consistently maintained that it is a
charity and never traded on Hillary
Clinton's position as Secretary of State
Brett we will follow all of these
threads Katzman thank you Mark